(cars honking)
- [Announcer] Hidden in New
York City's garment district,
on 37th Street, between 8th
and 9th Avenues, building 306,
lies a one-of-a-kind freight entrance,
and inside, you'll find deliveries
and something delicious.
You weren't expecting that, were you?
I told you it was hidden.
(upbeat music)
Inconspicuous at first,
but take a closer look
through these doors,
and you'll find a small but
mighty Latin American restaurant
called Aquario cafe.
Meet the owner.
Thank you, enjoy.
Enjoy.
(knife banging)
- [Announcer] The menu
is constantly changing,
but customers can usually
expect pollo guisado,
rabo guisado, espaguetis Dominicanos,
and the most popular of them all.
- Goat meat.
We gotta make everyday
because they love goat meat.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Announcer] But I know
what you're thinking.
Why choose to open a restaurant
in such a small place?
- [Announcer] He sells
hundreds of these plates a day,
and his success is all
thanks to word of mouth.
(speaking in foreign language)
I'm never going to move from here.
(quirky music)